il y a cinq ans le jeune david fortin
disparaissait de la maison familiale à
alma l'adolescent de 14 ans était
victime d'intimidation
il aurait vraisemblablement fugué cinq
ans plus tard ses parents sont toujours
sans nouvelles
pour souligner cet anniversaire ce
triste anniversaire l'organisme enfant
retour lance un programme pour réduire
les risques de fugue
julie martiaux une nouvelle formation
bientôt donner dans les écoles
secondaires de la province pour prévenir
les fugues qui représentent la majorité
des cas de disparition au québec pour
vous tirer les enfants écoutent
on sait qu'il ya vous avez des problèmes
mais c'est important de parler à
quelqu'un
l'objectif éviter des disparitions comme
celle de david fortin cet adolescent de
14 ans dalmat victime d'intimidation il
a fui la maison familiale
le 10 février 2009 ses parents ont
multiplié les recherches mais david
n'est jamais revenu 5000 disparitions
d'enfants
l'organisme enfant retour québec lance
son programme intitulé rester à
l'occasion du cinquième anniversaire de
cette triste disparition et les jeunes
là vous le cas de david fortin est
troublant personnes pensent que ça va
devenir aussi sérieux ma soeur parfois
fermiers mais sortira proche de l'
isolement ce n'est pas simple elle sait
pas vraiment comment réagir parce que
c'est difficile à seulement 10 ans et
jeune sabrina bien l'intention d'aider
sa petite soeur avec ses parents en
parler c'est le premier pas à franchir
selon la mère de david fortin
il faut parler soit par écrit soit
d'en parler de trouver quelqu'un de
confiance mais pourquoi que les tchèques
d'autres david fortin est d'ailleurs
cette enquête se poursuit jeunesse au
soleil a décidé d'offrir jusqu'à dix
mille dollars à toute personne qui
aurait des informations sur david fortin
et si joli marceaux radio canada
montréal